with us tonight we are at the start of
what will be a terrible week for your
President Joe Biden his approval rating
is already already now at an 80 year
record low he's losing to both Trump and
DeSantis in a head-to-head matchup uh
most Americans don't even think Joe is
mentally fit to serve most Democrats
they want someone else to be president
and now Biden's primary Challenger
Robert Kennedy Jr is already polling at
19 and 20 percent in two separate polls
now in just a moment by the way RFK Jr
will join us live right here on this
program we'll ask him about Joe Biden
why Biden won't debate him we'll also
ask him about this take a look
do you believe they murdered or were
involved in the murder of your uncle
what have you come to personally yes
they were definitely involved in the
murder wow Robert uh Kennedy Jr will be
here straight ahead now of course
Biden's bad week is not just because of
bad polling or a strong Challenge from
RFK Jr it also doesn't have anything to
do with the insanity at the southern
border with uh title 42 is now set to
expire this Thursday the situation as we
all know is completely out of control we
have waves of illegal immigrants now
lined up as far as the eye can see just
waiting to cross over the weekend border
patrol they process get this a whopping
26 000 apprehensions uh documented 7 400
quote gotaways arrested a wanted felon
three sex offenders and a gang member
and they also confiscated hundreds of
pounds of drugs including meth cocaine
Fentanyl and heroin but Joe Biden well
he says the borders secure it doesn't
care at all about any of that he could
care less about the Border instead this
week well he's more worried about his
wonderful son Hunter who might soon be
headed to prison now Joe is now beside
himself he just can't believe it in fact
the big guy well he told msdnc that
Hunter has done absolutely positively
nothing wrong although he never had a
conversation with hunter ever about his
foreign business dealing so how would he
know take a look
my son's done nothing wrong
I trust him I have faith in him and it
impacts my presidency by making me feel
proud of him
here's what it gets very interesting
Federal officials now reportedly even
the mainstream media mob reporting that
they are now near an indictment on
felony tax evasion charges and a felony
gun crime but house oversight committee
chairman James Comer is pleading with
the doj to wait according to Comer
Biden's doj is barely scraping the
surface take a look at this
my message to the Department of Justice
is very loud and clear do not indict
Hunter Biden before Wednesday when you
have the opportunity to see the evidence
that the house oversight committee will
produce with respect to the web of llc's
with respect to the number of
adversarial countries that this family
influence peddled in this is not just
about the president's son this is about
the entire Biden family including the
president of the United States so we
believe there are a whole lot of
accounts that the IRS and the doj don't
know about because we don't believe
they've done a whole lot of digging in
this and we have right now chairman
Comer he will be with us on Wednesday
with all the details from that major
announcement but so far it appears that
Comer's investigation is focused on
allegations against the president
himself and get this according to a new
report from John Solomon we are now
learning that a respected former U.S
attorney approached the doj in 2018
quote on behalf of a foreign witness who
claimed to have evidence that Joe Biden
exercised influence to protect his son's
employer in Ukraine in return for money
to his family the allegation States
quote VP Biden and Secretary of State
Kerry exercised influence to protect
Barista Holdings in exchange for
payments to Hunter Biden his business
partner Devin Archer and Joe Biden now
if that's true it might explain why
Hunter and his business partner were
receiving huge monthly payments in
exchange for sitting on the board of
that Ukrainian in oil and gas giant
without any experience in Ukraine energy
oil gas you name it and it might also
explain why Joe is Vice President he
pushed so hard he leveraged one billion
U.S tax dollars to get a Ukrainian
prosecutor fired in six hours a
prosecutor who was investigating barisma
and his son for corruption by the way
son of a bee they fired the guy now keep
in mind a few days ago chairman Comer
subpoenaed and FBI and doj document
detailing a possible criminal bribery
scheme involving then Vice President
Biden after it was brought to culmer's
attention by a whistleblower and make no
mistakes these are very very serious
allegations against the big guy himself
but will Justice ever be served now we
have reached out to the White House for
comment they don't seem to like US state
we never hear back from them we're very
nice people too hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube age and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else